in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week
I'm in the Charity Hospital in the heart
of Berlin of the Department of
Dermatology with Professor Maura thanks
for inviting me and you're an expert in
utak area normally when I press on my
skin nothing happens at all but
impatient with hives it's totally
different why is that the reason for
this is that they have beauty kiria
chronic inducible utak area which means
that you can induce hives or angioedema
by external triggers pressure is one of
them sunlight is one of them called and
others and this is a chronic disease so
many of these patients have problems for
months and years and what actually
happens in the skin the cells in the
skin that are meant to protect us from
danger coming from the outside overreact
they're hypersensitive to triggers such
as cold or pressure and they produce a
defense reaction in an inflammatory
reaction which then manifests with
wheels or with hives with redness with
itch and angioedema so this sounds to me
like it's in kind of allergic reaction
because the immune system fights and the
own tissue of the body so it's that kind
of allergy well it looks like an allergy
and in the end you go to an allergist
and he gives you an anti-allergic drug
so there are many similarities the
difference is that in your attic area
the immune system is not involved in the
way that it is in allergist we don't
have antibodies to environmental
allergens such as pollen or foods in
patients with utak area that are
responsible for their problems it's
other underlying causes that lead to
chronic urticaria is the skin the only
target organ which is affected by utak
area this is a very good question
because we know that must cells are the
responsible cells for utak area and we
have muscles not only in the skin but
also in the Airways and in the gut so
why is it that only the skin mast cells
release their histamine and make
problems we don't know yet but a lot of
research projects are focused on that so
I hope we will have an answer in the
future so if only the skin is affected
and it's itchy a little bit a little bit
so these are the only symptoms for the
is it a severe disease slimness yeah
this is a very severe disease and the
main reason for this is that patients
are very itchy
these hives and the other symptoms that
come with your tech area are immensely
itchy and you can sleep when you have
you to care you can't work you can focus
you can't concentrate and you have this
every day or almost every day for a long
time so it's one of the worst skin
diseases that you can have usually it
takes a long time
sin until the diagnosis is made and why
is that is it so difficult to diagnose
this disease well it's not that
difficult to diagnose when you have
hives or angioedema your cheek area is
the most likely explanation for this so
diagnosis is not the main challenge
treating these patients well is what
they need a good doctor what they need a
good elegance or dermatologists for all
right so how do you diagnose it actually
by looking at the skin when there are
hives or angioedema we can diagnose you
to Kerry and most patients the problem
sometimes is that patients were not and
they are in my office they don't have
the hives they don't have the angioedema
so we need good pictures good
documentation of what the skin looks
like and then it's not that hard to die
professor Malwa patients actually can
die from a cold urticaria that is
correct
it's one of the most dangerous forms of
chronic urticaria why patients swim they
go into cold water
their skin mass cells react they release
a lot of histamine which goes to all
parts of the body including the brain
they get like an allergic shock and they
become unconscious and they drown the
second dangerous situation is when
patients drink something that's colder
than they tolerate or eat ice cream then
their tongue starts to swell the Airways
get tight and they can suffocate from
this UT carrier reaction and you got a
patient on your walk with cold urticaria
and you invited us to join you during
the consultation that's right
I hate okay good talk nice beating you
money cuz our patient in she suffers
from you to carry and she doesn't speak
English so I do the talk in German and I
ask question like when did it first
start and Hamza Deena the estimate of
America's you know tikka really that's
so it was about thirty years ago I was
working for the police force and was
outside all the time and after a while I
started getting this puffiness and
itching and that's when I found out that
I was I was it was neat life as a human
Acharya honey she didn't know that it
was a kind of unique area that was known
I didn't know that
not even the dermatologists knew that it
was only here that I got help the normal
dermatologists are not so well informed
about this kind of condition and didn't
really know how to treat it either some
of you in the Department of Professor
MoMA and you developed a machine who
helps you in diagnosing chaotic area
that's right with our partners we
developed a machine that allows us to
diagnose and test patients with coal
Tudyk areas right here so we can see how
it works okay let's do this
this is the device to test the critical
temperature threshold a machine a device
that produces all temperatures from four
degrees to 44 degrees we can expose the
skin of the patient to all these
different temperatures to see what is
the warmest cold that is sufficient for
you to produce a wheel what I need from
you is your arm you will put the arm for
five minutes
five minutes on to this device and we
will wait now afterwards we will take
the arm off and we will see by the
length of the reel what your individual
temperature threshold is this is
important for patients because they can
better avoid temperatures that are
dangerous for them we do this then
provide treatment and then do it again
so that we can see if we have lowered
the temperature threshold and protected
our patients from this hypersensitivity
to pull so do we see anything well now
we have to wait a little bit because of
course you can not see much now and that
is because now the skin starts to
develop the wheels and in five ten
minutes we will see a reel that will
start here start here and depending on
how long the wheel will be we can
measure with this that sensitivity of
the patient and then - and how does it
feel if you put your arm on the machine
is it very cold or is it painful at
first it's not cold but after about five
minutes it starts to get itchy that's
what's happening right now I'd like to
scratch myself now but I'm not allowed
to and after about 10 minutes the rash
will probably start to appear tell us
something about the modern forms of
treatment of this kinds of you - carrier
well the first three
it happened right now we can tell Kaka
in five minutes what is her threshold
and she can better avoid the cold that
is critical for her one of the standard
treatments we use are non-sedating
modern antihistamines that block the
histamine and therefore the development
of wheels and what happens if the anti
allergic medication doesn't work one
very effective way to treat cold
urticaria is the use of an antibody anti
IgE antibody which is given
subcutaneously injected into the skin
every four weeks and can prevent wheels
and angioedema in most cold urticaria
patients treated with this treatment so
if the time is over for the test then we
can see what the results are we can see
the real already and if I pull apart the
skin a little bit you can see here in
the middle this I've probably very itchy
and what we do is we take our template
we put the template on to the and then
we see yes up to 17 degrees Celsius
that's your critical temperature
threshold so anything that's 17 degrees
cold or colder will produce these wheels
it's a very accurate and depressive test
thank you so much for inviting me into
your clinic and thank you for sharing
your story with us
you